bonjour j'ai décidé de faire cette vidéo
en plus des autres vidéos pour répondre
à vos questions
j'avais déjà fait ça en 2007
bonjour c'est si près l'a dit messi
dribble
j'ai été nul je vous ai demandé de poser
vos questions sur twitter avec le
hashtag cyprien répond et le hashtag est
devenu premier des trending topics ce
dans le monde
au bout de quelques minutes ce qui fait
que vous êtes des malades on va
commencer avec la question qui m'a été
posée le plus sur la planète terre je
dois la recevoir au moins une fois par
jour par email je ne sais pas pourquoi
ça vous passionne tant quel est ton
logiciel de montage
c'est fine gueule que deux pros sur mac
voilà je sais pas si ça change quelque
chose pour vous pourquoi
cyprien
[Musique]
parce que j'étais un enfant non désiré
et mes parents me l'ont fait savoir en
me donnant un prénom de merde je ne vois
que ça lit tu des mangas oui quels sont
tes mangas préférés
alors c'est dragon ball et j'étais au
très largement 1 on va dire que ces deux
mangas ont forgé l'homme immature que je
suis aujourd'hui
comptes tu travaillais la télévision
alors j'ai déjà travaillé pendant un an
et demi sur nrj12 j'avais deux petites
émissions quotidiennes et j'ai arrêté
pour pouvoir faire des vidéos sur
internet et je pense que c'est beaucoup
mieux comme ça en tout cas moi je
préfère très largement je préfère passer
du temps avec vous tout simplement
j'aimerais toucher les seins de nabila
[Musique]
est ce que tu aimerais touché deux
ballons en plastique
tu as ta réponse qui est on youtube
heures préféré jacques cet homme ce cas
c'est un anglais qui fait des vidéos des
films d'animation totalement absurde et
je rigole très très fort beaucoup et en
france je pense que c'est suricates
parce que ces gens ne sont pas normaux
et ça me plaît franklin mikel ou très
fort très fort parce que c'est un
dangereux psychopathe
qu'est ce qui t'a donné envie de créer
la chaîne cyprien gaming et pourquoi
avoir choisi squeeze alors j'ai toujours
été passionné de jeux vidéo j'ai même
fait des dessins pour parler de
l'actualité des jeux vidéo en 2006 sur
un blog
et puis j'ai découvert la chaîne
smos games qui est la chaîne gaming de
ce match les peut-être les youtuber les
américains les plus connus et je me suis
dit il faut vraiment que quand il n'y a
que je crée moi aussi ce genre de vidéos
parce que j'avais envie d'en faire
depuis depuis toujours
et voilà donc j'ai créé cette chaîne il
ya des vidéos chaque semaine et si j'ai
choisi squeeze sais pas ce que je
cherchais un youtuber gaming qui se
mettaient pas mal en scène je voulais
faire ça avec quelqu'un qui se montrait
pas mal et qui faisait pas mal de
compass qui filmait juste son écran en
train de jouer et donc c'est tomber sous
le sens et je pense que squeeze est pour
moi le meilleur youtuber gaming comment
fais tu pour te masturber comme ça tu
fais quoi chez toi lorsqu'il n'ya
personne
quel est ton sport préféré
tu sauras à la paris games week
oui si j'ai pas trop de travail à ce
moment là mais normalement oui tu mesure
combien de m tu combien de mètres de
désolé de te dire ça comme ça monsieur
mais vous avez des problèmes avec les
distances or si tu veux là je vais me
pêché une truite grande comme ça en
kilos médecin qui dirait à peu près dont
je mesure 1 m 79 là pour répondre à ta
question
c'est une taille plutôt moyenne c'est
comme un mètre 80 en moins bien mais
pourquoi tu porte des lunettes
parce que si je les enlève je vois comme
ça
ce qui me semble évident que j'en porte
donc plutôt blonde ou brune
alors plutôt brune même franchement
brune
même si tout le monde sait que mon genre
de filles ce sont surtout les idées
glace édenté bien grosse avec des
croûtes entre les bourrelets un oeil de
verre qui boite on t'a dit que tu
ressemblais aux mecs de cyprien gaming
on importe quoi et 2.9 au [ __ ]
pourquoi
très bonne question
on dirait un petit peu une question de
10 heures de philo un peu pourquoi vous
avez quatre heures un monsieur oui
pourquoi nous avait quatre heures
aimes-tu frappé ton pénis sur des objets
durs du style tables chaises chihuahua
cortex comment tu sais j'adore monsieur
dream norman squeeze jérôme je me
marierai avec vous plus tard alors déjà
ce n'est pas une question et je crois
que c'est interdit par la loi
et enfin peux tu nous faire ton plus
beau to work
non voilà merci pour toutes vos
questions malheureusement j'ai pas pu
répondre à tous parce que ce n'est pas
humain tout simplement
et si ça vous a intéressé bas n'hésitez
pas à lire dans les commentaires
comme ça je referai d'autres par la
suite à bientôt
[Musique]